The most human trait is to want to know why.
And in a year that tested everyone around the world,...
..."why" was searched more than ever.
The spread of the coronavirus has passed a significant milestone.
And while we didn't find all the answers, we kept asking.
Some questions inspired joy; others, excitement.
Life in the bubble, whoo!
Do you love me?
Yes.
I don't know what an improper fraction is.
Teachers should make a billion dollars.
We found toilet tissue, y'all.
Put it on there, and start it up for me.
What are y'all doing?
It's still March, how many days in March?
Some questions made us cry.
You know, we've been through our ups and been through our downs.
I think the most important part is that we all stay together throughout.
I love you guys!
Some made us worry about this spinning rock we call home.
Fires were detected in the Amazon rainforest.
Why were so many lives lost?
Almost 1.5 million people have now died of COVID-19 worldwide.
Why are we still asking the same questions?
George Floyd repeatedly told the officers that he could not breathe.
So why do we still have strength to continue?
I believe in your power.
I believe in our power.
Chants of "Black Lives Matter" echoed from thousands of protesters...
...in cities around the world.
Why are we not defeated?
We have made too much progress, and we are not going back.
We are going forward.